we're asked to move the dot to 7 6 on
the number line so pause this video i
can move this dot right over here but i
encourage you pause the video and put
your finger on where 7 6 would be on the
number line
all right now let's work on this
together so what they're saying is is
from 0
to this point on the number line right
over there that gets us to 1 6. so each
of these spaces are a sixth so we go 0
7 6. let me make sure i got that so each
of these are a sixth so we have 1
so that's 7 6 on that number line
now they have other ways of getting at
the same idea for example they say which
point is at nine fourths on the number
line and they ask us to choose one
answer and we can look at the choices
here so which choice shows nine fourths
on the number line pause this video and
see if you can pick that
all right now let's look at each of
these so it looks like in choice in this
first choice the space between zero and
one
is split into one two three four equal
spaces so as we go from zero to this
next line that's a fourth and that seems
like it keeps going
so this is one-fourth two-fourths
three-fourths four-fourths five-fourths
six-fourths
fourths eight fourths
nine fourths is here that's what we're
looking for but the dot is not at nine
fourths it's at ten fourths eleven
fourths it's at twelve fourths so i
don't like choice a
let's see choice
b
let's see what is let's see we have
divided the space between zero and one
into one two three four five six equal
spaces
so each of these are a sixth
so to go from zero to one you've already
gone six sixths and then seven sixths
eight sixths nine sixths so this is nine
sixths not nine fourths and so let's
look at this last choice i'm already
feeling like it should be the answer but
we can see that the spaces are the same
as in our first choice so these are each
fourths once again i know that because
the space between zero and one or any
two whole numbers is divided into four
equal spaces
so to go from zero to one you go four
fourths and then five fourths six
fourths seven fourths eight fourths and
nine fourths so choice c is definitely
looking good let's do one more example
so here they say what fraction is
located at point a on the number line
pause this video and see if you can
answer that
all right
so between whole numbers how many spaces
equal spaces do we have it looks like we
have one
two
three four
five six equal spaces
so
things are divided into sixths so 1 6 2
6 3 6 4 6 5 6
6 6
which is equal to 1 and then
7 6
so
this is
7
over 6 just like that and we are done